>> WE'LL GOIE IT LES O'BRIEN ANI
GOVERNORE STATE
ARE TRACKINGNEWHISTENTIO A LOCAL
TUPOLO WALRT
CAINWAS GONTENTIONALLY HIS PLANE
IPELO
AISTETTH
WALMART STORE AND THE
WE'VE REACHET TO
HAVE YET TO RECEIVE COMMT.HATHAN
ICS WHO ARE THRST NTACT,S THISSE
CIRCLINGAT W
THIS IS THE STATEMENT RELEASED
TUPE PMENTLOCALI BEEN IN CH THE
A KING AIR,
ENGINE AAFT.
AVIATION TELN TH
THINK OF A TAIL A PLANE,T LIKE
IT ALSO TELLS YOU ABTHAND HAN I.
WE ALSN AVIATION
EXPERT TELLING CNN
BE
ANE AS
NGTU, HE I
EST MAJOS HIONLY
NDLES AW
R A  BIGGER
TARGETF TENTIONALLY CRASH.
BORIS,RO IS ACTUALLY
I COVERI
THTER ISS A
RESULT OF INTENSE FLOODING. I NO
MUCH.T'S BRING BACK IMI
O'BRIEN.
MILES, THE PLANE IS SAIDBE
VEA SENSE OF SCATLDOHA
T TELL YOU ABOUT THE TUATIORT OS
PING WET ON THE RAMP
THEY FIRST CAMOUT  TT          .
'6 ITI
VERY SUCCESSFUL,BEECHCRAFT WNODU
TO SAY MUCH MORE ABOUTGE
WHICIS NOW HAN FOUR HOURS, ID
IF HCH AT 5:00 A. CA, IT'S
EASTN.ETTINGE END OF HIS
FUEL, DEPEG
PARAMETERS AND E
ARE SET.
Y SOMETHING THATE QUITE BI
BU
THE TAIL
I WOULPOINT NE
THERE  S UND WAY
TOHIS AIRCRAFT AT  IN THE AIR H
RESOURORTY
AIRCRAFTN TOET
EE WHAT'GOVERY TROUBLILEASOU TAT
ALS IN THAT AREATIFIEDWE?N, IF U
OF SOME ND, IT WOULDT EACHG AIRI
FLYING.
E NEAREST AIR NATIONAL
GUARD BAUTRE GOING OHAT
RCY  UNDERN D TH AIRCRAFINGREAT
TROUBLING THREAT.
AS TIME GOESN AND TH SCARCE, THI
SITUATIOLLTO A HEAD,
E F PHYSIC .
>> MILES, I'WOERTHING.IMAGINE T
YOU MENTIONED AIR NATIONAL
GUARD.
IS TRER THIS ND
>> WELL, I MEAN, COULD
D THE
SHANKSVIE,A.TIONAL GUARDFT
ON THAT HORRAYE DEERED BY OSER
NOT EVENRMED, THOSUARD AIRCRAFT.
WHETHER THN
FIJE WHETHER
E IN ANYAY
APRIAT DING LIKE
THAT, WAYO MY NDING RATIONI DO T
OW9/BEENAWEN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT AT SOMENTURE,
A HORRIB TINER, IS
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS CASE IS, NE